بينما ينمو الصراع مع إيران بعيدًا عن
طاولات المفاوضات النووية
، تسمع الصواريخ فوق سوريا وإسرائيل أن
الحرب بالوكالة تأخذ منعطفًا أكثر وحشية
غير مرئي ، فهذه هي مدينة
tyese اليمنية حيث انتشرت حرب قبيحة بالفعل وتطحن
أنقاض الحياة  في الغبار ، تُظهر هذه الصور النادرة للطائرات بدون طيار
كيف بالكاد ترك جدار
سالماً ، وقد تم كسر بعض هذا من قبل
القوات الجوية السعودية بتوجيه
وتجهيز من الولايات المتحدة.  قصف
قوات الحوثي التي تدعمها إيران
بقذائف الهاون الحوثية أدى إلى تدمير أجزاء من المدينة -
والقتال الفوضوي ثلاثي المحاور
في الجبهة الأمامية بين
مليشيات كانت ذات مرة في نفس الجانب
والقناصة الإيرانيين ، سقطت ألغام الفوضى التي
خلفتها وراءها في المنطقة.  الدليل الأكثر تضررًا في
جميع أنحاء المدينة هو أنك تريد
إخفاء وجهه لأن عمال الإغاثة مستهدفون
هنا ، لقد جاء من واشنطن العاصمة
للمساعدة التي احتاجتها إلى اندلاع الحرب وبدأ
مؤسسة خيرية هناك قول مأثور في
الولاية يقول عندما تلقيك الحياة بالليمون
صنع عصير الليمون وبدأت
بشكل أساسي في رعاية الجرحى
حسنًا ، الحوثيون موجودون هناك بالمناسبة
الآن
هذا هو الخط وهنا حيث
يرسلون قذائف الهاون إلى الإطارات من
تلك التلال هناك أقول دائمًا
إنه جميل جدًا
ولكن الوضع  أبعد ما يكون عن
الجمال ، أسوأ شيء هنا
إصابة الأطفال وفي المستشفيات
قبل أسبوع كانت هناك قذيفة هاون
هاجمت من الحوثيين
إلى ذلك الجار.  صادفت أنا و rhood وجودنا
في المستشفى ودخلت طفلة
صغيرة بقلبها كان من
الصعب جدًا رؤيتها كانت
تبلغ من العمر 8 سنوات تقريبًا ويمكنك أن ترى قلبها يضخ ،
إنه أمر غير إنساني
أعني من يرسل قذائف المحرك و
والصواريخ في وهذه هي المدينة الأكثر
ازدحامًا في اليمن التي تفتقر إليها البشرية ،
ولكنها أيضًا مثابرة هنا في
دوامات الغبار والأغطية البلاستيكية الممزقة ،
حيث يعد منزل عشرات
الآلاف من النازحين نفسك
لمواجهة الخسائر التي لا يمكن تصورها والتي يمكن أن يتسبب
فيها الجوع والمرض  طفلة رضيعة
خفّضت ما يقرب من قرصين من العظام
تزن 2 كيلوغرام ، وتقول والدتها ميريام
إن هذا على ما يبدو
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] ،
لقد نجوا من عائلتهم
لأننا شقيق زوجها وابنها
قُتلوا في غارة جوية كما تقول
تركهم مع أطفاله الستة لإطعام هؤلاء
الأطفال القادرين على درء
الأمراض لديهم صدمة أخرى لهضم
حسابات Siler وهو يلعب في العشب
مع صديقه الصغير FEMA.
استقر غير مكتمل ، يقول إنه يود
العودة إلى دياره ، لكن لا يزال هناك طلقات رصاص
وقصف هناك وفي اليمن حيث
يتمتع السعوديون بما يكفي من الأمريكيين من الدعم
والعزم ضد إيران للقتال ،
لن يعود أحد إلى الوطن حتى تُفقد أرواح كثيرة
وتحطم أولاً